until you are out there in the wind in
the rain with the people experiencing or
at least trying to get a sense for the
kind of experience they're going through
you'll never understand the context in
which your technologies are going to be
used it's not something you can imagine
or glean from secondary data or even
from video or anything until you're
there seeing how they grapple with the
issues that they're dealing with it's
almost impossible to really understand
that context you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
Amos Miller is a product strategist on
the Microsoft research next enabled team
and he's played a pivotal role in
bringing some of MSRs most innovative
research to users with disabilities he
also happens to be blind so he can
appreciate perhaps in ways others can't
the value of the technologies he works
on like soundscape an app which enhances
mobility independence through audio and
sound on today's podcast
Amos Miller answers burning questions
like how do you make a microwave
accessible what's the cocktail party
effect and how do you hear a landmark he
also talks about how researchers are
exploring the untapped potential of 3d
audio in virtual and augmented reality
applications unexplained how in the end
his work is not so much about making
technology more accessible but using
technology to make life more accessible
that and much more on this episode of
the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Amos Miller welcome to the podcast thank
you it's great to be here
you are unique in the Microsoft research
ecosystem
your work is mission driven your
personal life strongly informs your
professional life and will get more
specific in a bit but for starters and
broad strokes
tell us what gets you up in the morning
why do you do what you do I've always
been passionate about technology from a
very young age but really in the way
that it impacts people's lives and it's
not a mission that I necessarily knew
about when I went through my career and
experiences with technology but when I
look back I see that those are the areas
where I could see that a person feels
differently about themselves or about
the environment as a result of the
interaction that technology that's where
I thought okay that is having meaning to
this person and I have this huge
wonderful opportunity to do what I do in
Microsoft research to actually have
turned that passion into my day job
which is very I feel extremely fortunate
with that yeah and I sense I have to
pinch myself too and I'll say that it's
not that a dream well tell us a little
bit about your background and how that
plays into what you're doing here I'm
very much a person that grew up in the
technology world I also moved the number
of countries over my career and my life
I grew up in Israel I spent many years
in the UK in London I spent a few other
years in Asia in Singapore and now I'm
here so all of these aspects of my life
have been very important to me I also
happen to be blind I suffer from a
genetic eye condition called retinitis
pigmentosa it was diagnosed when I was
five and I gradually lost my sight
I started University with good enough
sites to manage and finish University
with a service dog and any kind of
technology I could find to help me read
the white board to help me read the text
on the computer and I'd say by the age
of 30 I totally stopped using my site
and that's when I really started living
life as a fully blind person let's talk
about your job for a second you're a
product strategist at Microsoft Research
so how would you describe what you do so
I work in the part of the organization
at Microsoft Research that looks at
really transferring technology ideas
into impact into a way that they impact
business impact people a good idea will
only have an impact when it's applied in
the right way in the right environment
so that the social the business the
technological context in which it
operates is going to make it thrive
otherwise it doesn't matter how good it
is it's not gonna have an impact right
so let's circle over to this previous
role you had which was in Microsoft's
digital advisory program and I bring it
up in as much as it speaks to how often
our previous work can inform our current
work and you referred to that time as
your customer facing life how does it
inform your role as a strategist today
what always energizes me is when I see
and observe the meaning and the impact
that technology can really have for
people and I don't say it lightly until
you are out there in the wind in the
rain with the people experiencing or at
least trying to get a sense for the kind
of experience they're going through
you'll never understand the context in
which your technology is going to be
used it's not something you can imagine
or glean from secondary data or even
from video anything until you're there
seeing how they grapple with the issues
that they are dealing with it's almost
impossible to really understand that
context
and the work that I've done in actually
my first nine years in Microsoft I
worked in a customer facing part of the
business in a strategic advisory
services today known as a new digital
advisory services it's work that we do
with our largest customers around the
world to really help them figure out how
they can transform their own businesses
and leverage advancements in technology
right so now as you are working in
Microsoft research as a product
strategist how does that transfer to
what you do today
first of all I want to introduce the
team that I work with which is the
enabled team in Microsoft Research and
the enabled team is looking at
technological innovations especially
with disabilities in mind in our case
our two primary groups are people with
ALS as a product strategist my role is
to work across the research engineering
marketing and customer segments and
really figure out and understand how we
can harness what we have from a
technology perspective and as an
organization to maximize and have that
impact that we aspire to have with that
community and that takes a great deal of
again going back to my earlier point
spending time with that community going
out there and spending time in my case
with other people who are blind because
I only know my own experience yes I
don't have everybody else's experience
the only way for me to learn about that
is to be out there and in our team every
developer goes out there to spend time
with end users because that's the only
way you can really get under the covers
and understand what's going all right
[Music]
so the website says you drive a research
program that seeks to understand and
invent accessibility in a world this is
the fun part
where AI agents and mixed reality are
the primary forms of interaction I fight
to meet a little bit let me let me
unpack that a little bit when we
traditionally think about accessibility
we think about how do you make something
accessible so how do you make a
microwave accessible well there isn't
anything inherently inaccessible in
putting a piece of pizza and warming it
up in the microwave the only reason it's
inaccessible is because the microwave
was designed in an inaccessible way it
could have been accessible from the
beginning sure but the world we are
moving to is it's not about me
operating the microwave it's not about
the accessibility of the microwave it's
about me preparing dinner for my family
that's the experience that I mean and
there's a bunch of technologies that
support that experience and that
experience is what I am seeking to make
an accessible and inclusive experience
ok that means that we are no longer
talking about the microwave we're
talking about a set of interactions that
involve people that involve technology
that involves physical things in the
environment it's not about making the
technology accessible it's about using
technology to make life more accessible
whether you are going for a walk with a
friend whether you're going to see a
movie with a friend whether it's sitting
in a meeting and brainstorming a
storyboard for video all of these are
experiences and the goal is how do you
make those experiences accessible
experiences that kind of gets you
thinking about accessibility in a very
different way where your interaction is
with the person that you're sitting in
front of the technology is just
in support of that interaction all right
as I'm researching the interview I find
myself thinking of the various solutions
maybe the technical guide dog mentality
like let's replace all these things with
technology that people have
traditionally used for independence and
the technology as it enters that
ecosystem some people might think the
aim is to replace those things but I
don't think that's the point of what's
going on here I'm all right that's right
there is a tendency when you come at a
problem with a technology solution to
look at what you are currently doing and
replace that with something that's
automatic right oh you're using a guide
dog how can I replace that guide dog and
give you a robot so I work on technology
that enhances mobility independence
through audio and sound which we'll talk
about in a minute right but often people
ask me how that work for people who
can't hear and the natural inclination
to them is to say oh okay well you'll
have to deliver the information in
different way the thing is that people
get a sense of this space in their
surroundings using the senses that they
have to me the question is not how do we
shortcut that it's how do they sense
their space today they do they don't sit
there feeling completely disconnected
and if you are going to intervene in
that you better be consistent with how
they experiencing it today yeah and that
leads me right into the next question
because you and I talked earlier about
the fundamental role that design plays
in the success of human-computer
interaction and I'm really eager to have
you weigh in on the topic let's frame
this broadly in terms of assumptions and
that's kind of what you were just
referring to yeah you know if I'm
looking at you and I think well my
solution to how you interact with the
world with technology would be Braille
that's an assumption so I'm just going
to give you free rein here tell us what
you want us to know about this from your
perspective we all make
assumptions about other people's
experience of life you're referring to
bill Bergson who was on your podcast a
few weeks ago and he's actually been a
very close friend and mentor throughout
the work that we're doing on soundscape
which we'll talk about in a minute
and he's really brought to our attention
that what we've done of going out there
and experiencing the real situation that
people are experiencing is about empathy
and it's about trying to understand and
probe ideas that challenge your
assumptions about what effect they will
have but really seeing observing and
understanding their experience in that
particular situation and then maybe
applying from your learning some form of
intervention into that experience and
observing how that affects that
experience it doesn't have to be a
complete piece of software technology
it's just an intervention it can be
completely Lofa so that helps you to
start expanding your understanding and
you don't have to do it with a hundred
paper do it with 2/3 people you will
discover a whole new world you didn't
know about I'm sorry but you don't need
200 data points to support that
experience you've just seen it and you
can build on that
so can you enhance that in any way to
give them an even richer awareness of
the surrounding and those are the kind
of questions that taking design through
that very experiential lens has led us
to the work that we actually do on our
work on soundscape which is the
technology that we've been developing
over the last few years to really see
how far we can take this notion of how
people perceive the world and how you
can enhance that so their perception is
enhanced
[Music]
well let's talk about 3d sound and an
exciting launch earlier this year in the
form of Microsoft soundscape and this is
such a cool technology with so many
angles to talk about first just give our
listeners an overview of soundscape what
is it who's it for how does it work how
do people experience it sounds Kappa the
technology that we developed in
collaboration with guide dogs suddenly
in the early stages and still do and the
idea is very much using audio that's
played in 3d using a stereo headset you
can hear the landmarks that are around
you and you can thereby really enrich
your awareness of your surroundings of
what's where in a very natural easy way
and that really helps you feel more
independent more confident to explore
the world beyond what you know how do
you hear a landmark how do you hear a
landmark so for example if you're
standing and Starbucks is in front of
you and to the right we will say the
word Starbucks but we won't say it's in
front of you in to the right it will
sound like it is over there where
Starbucks is okay and that's generated
using the technical term is head
rotation transfer of synthetic binaural
audio so it's work that actually was
developed in Microsoft research over a
movie is my event of any steam and
effectively you can generate sound to
make it sound like it's not in between
your ears you can hear it as though it's
out in the space around you and it's
really quite amazing and we also use non
audio cues for example one of the ideas
that we built into soundscape is this
notion of a virtual audio beacon
not to be confused with Bluetooth
beacons it's completely virtual but
let's suppose you're standing on a
street corner and you are heading to a
restaurant that's a block and a half
away what you can do a soundscape is
place an audio beacon that will sound
like it's coming from that restaurant so
no matter which way you're standing
which way heading you can always hear
that
click click sound so you know exactly
where that restaurant is you can see it
with your ears how do you do that how do
you place a beacon someplace
technically binaural audio is when you
have a slightly different sound in each
ear which tricks the brain into having a
sense of sound it's three-dimensional
it's exactly the same way that 3d images
work audio works almost the same if
event was here you say it's not exactly
the same but by generating a slightly
different sound wave in each ear you are
able to make sound sound like it's
coming from a specific direction but by
playing it in each ear slightly
differently it will actually sound like
it's coming from in front of you and to
the right okay now how do we know where
to place that region at present we it's
largely designed to be used outdoors so
we use GPS so we know where you are
standing we know where that restaurant
is so we have two coordinates to work
with we also estimate which way you're
facing so if you were facing the
restaurant we would want to play that
beacon right in front of you if you were
standing at 90 degrees to the restaurant
we'd want to make that beacon sound like
it's coming not only from your right ear
but a hundred meters away to your right
yeah and so taking all of those sensory
inputs and taking the information from
the map the GPS location the direction
we reproduce the sounding
in your stereo headset so you can hear
the direction of the sound and where
thing is the mod and the most amazing
things is this is all done in real time
completely dynamic so as you walk down
the street that restaurant may sound in
front of you at 45 degrees to your right
and as you progress you will hear it
getting closer and closer and further
and further to your right and further
and further to your right and if you
overshoot that it'll start to sound
behind you a little bit yeah now why is
this so important because I'm not going
to the restaurant on my own I'm there
with my kid or with my wife or with my
friend and if I were to hold the phone
with the GPS instructions and all of
that I can't hold the conversation with
that person at the same time because I'm
so engaged with the technology and we
talked earlier about how do you get the
technology to be in the background that
beacon sound is totally in the
background you don't have to think about
it you don't have to attend to it
mentally it's just there so you know
where the restaurant is and you continue
to have the conversation with the person
you're with
or you can daydream or you can read your
emails listen to a podcast and all of
that happens at the same time because
it's played in 3d space because it's
non-intrusive we minimize the use of
language and all of these subtle aspects
are absolutely crucial for this kind of
technology to be relevant to this
situation you're not sitting in front of
the computer and it's the only thing
you're doing you are outdoors it's a ton
of things happening all the time that
you have to deal with you can't expect
the person to disassociate themselves
from all of that you know soundscape is
one way of addressing it's very very
interesting an important question
throughout history technology has always
changed the way that we do things but I
think that we are starting to see that
as technology developers we really have
to be much more mindful about
just from the subtleties of how we
designed something on what is the
relationship between the technology and
the person in that situation how can a
technology do exactly the same as it has
done but do so in a way that makes the
person feel empowered and develop a new
skill great runners learn to feel their
heart beat but if they have a heart
monitor they'll stop feeling that
heartbeat because the device on their
wrist tells them what it is well that's
only because that's how it was designed
if the heart monitor instead of telling
you you're at
I don't know 150 it's a what do you
think you're at and you'd say oh I'm at
140 and you need to say oh you actually
had 150 he will have learned something
new from that it's exactly the same
function but you have developed yourself
as a result of that interaction and I
think that that's the kind of
opportunity that we need to start
looking for I want to circle back to
this 3d audio and the technology behind
it and something that you referred to as
the cocktail party effect can you
explain that a little bit and how
Microsoft Research is sort of leading
the way here the cocktail party effect
is an effect in the world of
psychoacoustics that is very simple if
you imagine is sitting around a table
and a cocktail party having a very
exciting conversation with somebody and
lots of other similar conversations
happening around you at the same time
because all of those conversations are
happening in 3d space you are actually
able to hear all of those conversations
even though you're attending just to
yours you're listening and you can
understand and engage in your
conversation but if your name came up in
any of those other conversations you'll
immediately turn your head and say hey
guys what are you talking about there
and that's an incredible capability of
the brain to manage a
very rich set of inputs in the auditory
space that is very much underutilized
today in a technology space we always
feel that if we need to convert
something into audio it's got to be
sequenced because we can only hear one
thing at a time when it's in 3d that's
no longer the case
and that's a huge opportunity we play a
lot of that in VR and augmented reality
and we spend a lot of time on the visual
aspect of virtual reality and really
pushing the envelope on how far we can
take the use of immersive experiences
and objects in all directions but the
same is available with audio even more
with audio because your eyes are no
longer engage audio is in 360 if we
block our ears for a moment all of a
sudden our awareness level jobs but we
are so unaware of the power of audio
because vision just takes over
everything and I think the work that we
have done both in the acoustic work on
3d audio and the application especially
in the disability space where we place
the constraints on the team there is no
vision now let's figure it out and that
leads to new frontiers of discovery and
innovation in this space that I think
could be applicable and would be
applicable in many other spaces and that
you know that heads up experience when
you're out and about in the streets not
focused on the screen but engaged in
your surrounding and that's a perfect
situation where audio has huge
advantages that we can look at
[Music]
I asked each of my guests
some version of the question what keeps
you up at night because I'm interested
in how researchers are addressing
unintended consequences of the work
they're doing is there anything that
concerns you Amos anything that keeps
you up at night
I think things keep me up at night
because they are so interesting and yet
unsolved you know we talked a bit about
how do you really express and portray
the physical space around you in ways
that utilize your other senses and
really maximize the ability of the brain
to make sense of places without vision
and I really think that way sounds great
we've only started to scratch the
surface of that question over half of
the brain is devoted to perception and I
think that when we find ways to really
engage even further engage that
incredible human capability we will
discover a whole new frontier of machine
human interaction in ways that we don't
understand today you said you arrived at
Microsoft Research from left field
what's your story on how you came to be
working on research and accessibility
and Microsoft research I started life as
a developer and did a business degree
and joined the strategic advisory
services in Microsoft consulting in the
UK and I think it was a very special
moment in Microsoft over the last few
years when we really started to
understand the meaning of impacting
every person on the planet with
technology and seeing that as our
mission and that led to a series of
conversations that will open an
opportunity for us to actually get
behind that statement and we basically
joined Microsoft Research through that
mission through the work that we're
doing in soundscape and because we
already had very strong relationships
thanks to some wonderful people in the
company
some relationships here in Microsoft
research and in other parts of the
company before we close bill Buxton
asked me to ask you about the kayak
regatta tell that story quickly because
I do have one question I wanna wrap up
with before we go okay what we talked
about soundscape as a technology that
really enables you to hear signals in 3d
around you and that was largely designed
to be used in the street right and then
we thought what would happen if we place
that audio beacon on a lake so we got a
bunch of people during the summer
hackathon and said okay well let's try
it out so we organized an event on Lake
Sammamish we hacked soundscape to work
on the lake and placed some virtual
audio beacons around the lake and
invited a group of people who are blind
to come and kayak with us and see how
they enjoy it and they absolutely loved
it and I think that was a real
eye-opener for us yeah you have to
understand the difference here and you
know could they kayak before sure no
problem because a sighted person would
be with them and would tell him ok now
you were straight now you're all left
but I'm sorry that's a very boring
experience you're not in control you're
not independent but just doing the work
[Music]
and by being able to hear where those
beacons are you are truly in the driving
seat and that is a sense of Independence
that we've not really seen to that
extent before we did this event I like
how you called it an eye-opening event
there's so many metaphors about vision
that we just sort of take for granted
right maybe it's because I have prior
sight maybe not but I first of all I use
those metaphors all the time and I also
feel you know I could close my eyes and
feel that my eyes are closed and open
them and open and I definitely take
everything in in a very different way
sure
even though the eyes don't actually do
the scientific aspect of what they're
designed today hmm as we close I always
ask my guests to offer some parting
advice to our listeners whether that be
in the form of inspiration for future
research or challenges that remain to be
solved or personal advice on next steps
along the career path whether you have a
guide dog with you or soundscape what
would you say to 25 year old self if
you're just getting started in this
arena I honestly would say get real-life
experience especially in the areas that
you're passionate about be passionate
about them with even more energy and see
the work that you do in the context of
what you're passionate about because you
can only really apply your personal
experience as to what you do it's so
great here in Microsoft research to see
the interns coming here in the summer
and the creativity and passion and new
perspectives that they bring to our work
here and there's a little bit of a side
of me that worried that they'll jump
into the job before they went out and
explored the world and I think it's
important that they find a way to do
something that gives them that
meaningful context to the work that
they'll be doing here Amos Miller thank
you for joining us today it's been can I
say it an eye-opening experience sure my
pleasure thanks so much for having me
[Music]
to learn more about a Miller and the
latest innovations in audio sound and
accessibility technology visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]